and I said there is no amount of money
that you could pay me
um but if I had done it and done it well
I could have progressed to a horse you
know how
um I love how off topic you go
it's just gold
[Music]
hey I'm Eva Eva oh and I currently work
as a dominatrix I used to be an escort
in brothels in massage parlors and I've
been doing all of this for over 10 years
now my name is Danny D I'm an adult
performer I've been working in the
industry since I was 18 I'm 33 now so 35
now so yeah enjoying the adult industry
hi I'm Caroline B
um I'm 70 now and I'm an escort I've
been doing it since 2017.
um absolutely love it I wish I'd started
it sooner actually
um but Olivia I do only fans I basically
started today I turned 18 and I just
kind of do like amateur content on
Mercedes I started working as a stripper
in 2021 and now I'm 22 and I started
only fans so yeah
my name is karma baba
um I started only fans about a year ago
and I'm gay
[Laughter]
kind of chat about it most sex workers
lie or don't tell their friends and
family about what they do
but I didn't tell my family for about
seven years
and around the point where I thought I
was going to tell them I prepped myself
for being disowned
but luckily my mother who's the most
important to me took about a month
to let it settle and then she came back
to me with questions like what are the
clients motivations what does that
interaction look like like what is your
motivation she really wanted to
understand it so I think I really
underestimated her
when I first started I didn't tell
anybody when I met them now I just tell
people from the get-go just like get it
out of the way
and then usually it's this huge load of
questions about the the job you know
they're fascinated by it more than
anything else these days
do most people not tell the people in
their lives I find that that can be the
case when you're first starting out for
sure
um because there's still a lot of stigma
around it even if it's decriminalized in
certain places but hopefully that shifts
but I think it's the same with the
swinging which is where I first started
is that my family found out by seeing
things online to this day I still do not
know what how much they know but
whatever it is they don't approve
obviously you know so that was the
family so we haven't spoken since which
is fine by me my friends I have a small
group of friends who I have told and
they fully support me and they love me
and they get excited with me telling
them the stories you know whatever I
feel like it just takes educating people
because my parents didn't know about
what I did and they have so many because
of the stigma and what they think is
like there's so many misconceptions and
preconceptions about what it's going to
be but if you inform them like over time
and not just dump it on them because I
had a very like specific plan I informed
my parents for like a whole year and I
drip fed them info and it's just like
the ignorance that they have about it
that makes them scared and makes them
think oh that's a really dangerous thing
like how naughty you shouldn't be doing
that but now that they actually know the
ins and outs and I've educated them on
it they're bloody fine with it and
they're Catholic doctors like they're
strict my mother's a bible school
teacher is she
it just takes like telling them the
internet so I am safe it's okay this is
how it works and then there'll be more
understanding I know some people you
can't change but like it just takes some
education because they just don't know
when I first started I was like still in
my last year of school because in
Ireland we only
um at least got like 18 so I was 18 and
like this is about a Christian School
like but I didn't want to waste any time
I just wanted to get crapping on it like
I've been waiting for ages to start one
so and all my friends like I hear people
talking about like only fans how they
didn't approve it and I was just like
hearing what my secret account this is
so awkward when people find out I wasn't
telling my mom or any of that but I used
to do my messages on like the family
laptop like I don't know what I was
thinking obviously one day I forgot to
log out so my mom's goes onto the laptop
to see and she's like oh she's like what
the [__] is this and she said she was
like she saw everything like I left my
home page up and I post pretty much
everything on the feed so she could just
see oh God it was just and then it just
came to me and I was like yeah not gonna
lie I'm doing this now and she was
trying like mad about ballistic so he
took her a feeling once but like she
came around and now as you're saying as
long as it's safe like
it doesn't really matter all my friends
back in Ireland like didn't agree with
that at all and but when I moved to the
UK then it's just not how open-minded
everyone is here so much more normal and
no one really did it back in Ireland at
the time so like everyone would just
look down on me basically but yeah it's
nice here no one really cares
well I still haven't told my family I
happen to my family I think with me like
I know my family wouldn't accept me as
being gay anyway so I was like well my
life is kind of difficult in itself like
I was I'm pretty much 80 sure I would be
discerned so I said to myself well if I
really only got gonna have myself
because for me I wouldn't I wouldn't
want to like I guess what I'm doing this
interview is like I wouldn't want to sit
somewhere and be around people who
really don't love me for the real me and
I guess they never really got to know
the room because I never like told them
of this after this I'm sure I have to
tell them right but for me it's like I'm
going to be discerned anyway I was like
let me look at my like
options in life what I want to do I want
to go about it so I was like I'm
definitely doing anything I was like I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna do it I'm not
gonna stop myself from doing it just
because
like family members and like friends for
example which I've lost like family like
friends and family over and stuff but
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna let that get
in the way of me like doing what I want
to do because I know this is something I
want to do for a while I think back in
2020 I did it for a month and there's so
much money I made in that one month but
then I chickened out because there's a
lot of pressure especially being a South
Asian gay guy and then my family's
Muslim so
there's a lot but
you just gotta have the balls to really
at the end today and yeah I'm glad I did
it I'm glad I mean my choices and I
wouldn't be here if I wasn't like
comfortable and proud of like what I do
and when I first got into porn I told my
mum straight away
um told my dad Etc and everyone was kind
of supportive and accepting
um my mum's been to Las Vegas for the
pawn Awards several times and she fully
Embraces it and um yeah so in terms of
that I've been incredibly lucky
the next one I was gonna say is it's
hard to maintain romantic relationship
as a sex worker
yeah I think it's very like
a very strong man that's not insecure to
like be able to be okay with their
girlfriend literally doing all this
online because well from my personal
experiences like I've had guys you know
their friends would like slag them and
they get a hard time like bring all your
girlfriends off doing this and that I
think it's important to to be honest
with yourself and with your partner and
find someone who understands you as a
person at the end of the day we do this
because we love it no one's forced us or
coerced us to be here and it's something
that's a part of us and I think if
you're if you can be honest with your
partner and communicate that this is you
if it's the right person for you again
we're not saying it's easy it's
definitely a very challenging task to
love someone in the adult industry and
be with them but it can it can be
fruitful if you find the right person
but I would definitely agree it's not an
easy thing to to achieve I think think
there's a part of it that makes it not
easy and that society makes it difficult
for them but I think that people
like sex workers who are dealing with
people all the time we have a lot of
skills that a lot of other people don't
I kind of feel like I just tell people
I'm a sex worker and if you're not going
to take that there's like a really good
filter to just push you aside I think we
have to we can't be blind to the fact
that things change the day that you meet
someone you may say hey I'm a sex worker
I'm a porn star and only fans go
whatever it may be and day one someone
may be fully okay with that and they
might be open with it but unfortunately
things change and when you fall in love
if you can hit these markers you know
the six months the 12 months the 18
months they're big steps in a
relationship they don't seem to be able
to recognize the difference between like
you and your job or you as a person and
I always say that it's the same as like
if you go to Disneyland and you see
Cinderella and they're like you know
that's the real Cinderella it's not an
actress
and that's what it's like with yourself
and it's like come on it's a job it's
like the whole of you there's more to
you than just your job sex work has a
shelf life
[Laughter]
I feel like it better I feel that my
skill set grows you know and you learn
more about how people are and you take
this and you get more successful faster
when it comes to particular clients and
your skills just get better so I don't
really see the validity of that and
there's always a market for
all sorts of different looks also
different ages all sorts of different
approaches there's literally a market
for pretty much anything yeah I know
escorts that are 85 and still doing it
yeah
yeah you know I want to do it when I'm
100 if I get that far
why not if you fit and you're able and
people well I guess there is a physical
aspect sometimes well this is it yeah I
mean as long as I've still got my
marbles and you know I can
do the necessary then why not
that's been thinking from a guy's
perspective and from what I do I mean
there is kind of a shelf life on
whatever on what I do obviously if my
winky doesn't work then I can't work but
as far as in terms of a shelf life like
you said there is a niche for everything
um
personally if I will me out at 85 I'll
be happy as Larry to keep going but you
know I'm not blind to the fact that
there is a kind of a shelf life for me
anyway
um but as adult or sex work as a whole I
believe like you said there is a niche
for everything and it doesn't
necessarily mean the curtains close at
40 50 60 or whatever I think you can
adapt in this industry and change it's a
question I get all the time like oh what
are you gonna do in your
Europe's been inspired in here like
it'll be 24 soon then you're a MILF
don't worry
think that more people actually
pay for sex more people watch porn more
people have connection to sex industry
in any of those ways then they admit
for sure oh yeah yeah people definitely
pay for porn pay for sex workers
whatever maybe definitely contribute to
the adult industry more than that is
discussed about and it's because it's an
open topic isn't it it's something that
you can easily talk about you can easily
talk about lots of things but sort of
getting into your your niches and your
your kinks and your fetishes doesn't
necessarily come out in the boys group
too often you know to say oh when I met
a lovely granny the other day had a
wonderful time thinking to marrying that
you know it doesn't just normally come
out you know whereas you can say oh
watch the EastEnders the other night
that was great
um
but yeah I find it it's not a talked
about thing but at the end of the day
you just have to open your eyes look how
many people are on only fans are
stripping or hooking it's a big business
there's not many people like me
especially in the UK I don't think
there's many like gay South Asian guys
doing any fans so I'll get a good mix a
good mix of it and
a lot of them are kind of like they
really are they're real they really like
me like because I guess it's hard like
like almost like a rare like a rare
thing to see so I have the whole thing
but I definitely a lot of other South
Asian men because I feel like sometimes
with porn and stuff like that where I
like
sometimes for them it's about like kind
of seeing themselves or seeing someone
they relate to in that kind of age I
mean or you know someone there I guess
attracted to you in that country so I've
seen a lot of stuff there's a lot of
South Asian fans basically that's all
majority of it is but then even in
America the USA guys not so much the
ukis but the USA USA guys they love me
they eat me up like it's so different
than the UK I mean I get all ages
basically the lower ages 18.
um that's what I regard as the the
lowest I'll go to
um and the oldest is probably 80.
um so they're any age any nationality
um they come from all over the world
when they're in London they'll contact
me and say I'm coming over to London in
you know in August could I come and see
you
yeah no problem they've all got a
fantasy you know and they just want that
fulfilled which is quite often why they
come it's not because they just want sex
it's because they've got a fantasy and
whoever they're with either isn't
willing to do that fantasy with them
um so they need to go somewhere to find
somebody who will are we all supposed to
are us ladies all supposed to fantasize
all day and every day like men do you
know or they're all going every day you
know and understanding about who they
want to meet and which granny they want
to find
to fulfill it
and one of the weirdest ones was asking
me to dog off
I mean you know
you have to you have to question don't
you what's going on up there when that's
what they want um no it was giving give
the dog first time give the job for a
thousand pounds
and then how much to stop the dog off
and I said there is no amount of money
that you could pay me
um but if I had done it and done it well
I could have progressed to a horse you
know how
just thinking what's going on in their
mind you know
um I love how off topic you go it's just
Gold
Guys
caught some requests and he was like oh
so how much are customers I'll turn the
price is like okay so what's your
request he's like I want this dildo but
yeah it's a specific dildo I was like
okay like no problem send me the link
and he's like I'll pay for it okay so he
sends me the link of the deal though
it's a dog a dildo I was like oh I don't
know I'm pretty open I think that might
be stepping over a line I mean these
days because of my price point I mostly
see rich white men but when I first
started because you know the world is
unfair and therefore a lot of money goes
to white man older white men and but
when I first started I started at like
I'm about a thousand an hour now and you
started at about 6 75 for half an hour
when I first started and the range was
much more vast and again it's like from
legal age to on the way out so it's
broad spectrum yeah yeah I think the
adult industry in whole is is for that
reason isn't it it's to fulfill the
desires you know whether you are single
whether you're in a relationship in a
marriage you might dream of a threesome
and the idea is you can now watch it and
enjoy that moment or you can pay for
that moment and enjoy it you know I
think the industry is dealing with that
that's what we kind of provide we
fulfill fantasies and I think anyone
kind of looking into our industry or
participating whether they're a viewer
or a client or whatever they they have
some itch that needs to be scratched and
that's kind of the service we provide in
just different various formats
and also the compartmentalization of it
like sometimes I want that threesome but
I don't want all the trouble around 100
is paying them to leave you know if
you're married and you just want to have
sex with someone and do a doggy position
your wife won't do it it's
not saying that that's right but you
know that's the the need that's the itch
that's scratched I think and then the
other people of course the people who
are actually in like relationships and
stuff straight relationships as well so
that's different than actually having
basically like having a Hall of Fame and
stuff I think it's just the easy option
it's just so much my director and pay
like what 999 and just get your box off
whatever and keep it moving most of the
sex workers have high sex drive and have
a lot of sex in their personal life
what was the last bit of that and have a
lot of sex in their personal life too
oh okay okay I've been celibate for the
whole last year I haven't had sex for a
while a year in a bit my name's Danny
choice or on
noise I did try to have sex with people
but they didn't want me so yeah it
wasn't actually my choice but then I was
kind of proud of myself like wow A Year
Without sex can I ask if you've also
been like self-pleasuring yeah but just
for work oh okay okay yeah I'm pretty
active to be fair but like you know my
only fans a lot of sex on there that's
kind of what I do so yeah I would say hi
sex drive personally yeah
I don't know whether I have or not
I keep getting asked are you horny today
and I still believe it or not I haven't
worked out what it feels like I'm
supposed to feel like to be horny I mean
no I don't go around all day thinking oh
yeah
you know I mean that's not my my life I
mean I enjoy sex does it ever come to
your mind like oh I would like to do
that only when I'm with the person okay
okay so I get turned on by or Not by the
person I'm with and yes I've had some
lovely clients yeah and you know I've
got oh yeah you know out the dog oh gosh
come in you know welcome how long can
you stay
what's your budget
exactly how much you pick up so that's
on the spur of the moment when I've met
somebody but I because I'm also a
swinger I have another outlet for
getting sex I'm not in a relationship I
haven't been in a relationship from the
donkeys years but I enjoy the swinging
and I have got a group of friends who I
have sex with you know and we go to the
clubs and and I enjoy that side of it so
I've got that outlet as well but I'm not
sitting there all day thinking I want to
have sex with somebody you know but when
I'm either having a client or going to a
club then yeah I'm looking forward to it
um
yeah I think initially I was I was very
um into sex I was quite had quite a high
sex drive
um obviously for the drive to trying to
want to join the adult industry
but I think as I kind of got older and
um I still have a high sex drive still
have a lot of sex but I definitely now
have a difference between work sex and
home sex I think Phil when I first
started in the industry I couldn't
really
tell the difference I was just having
sex and having fun and enjoying all of
it and and now I'm kind of very
understanding of this is work sex and I
have to perform and showcase a talent
and make her look as best as I can
whereas at home I can kiss and cuddle
and close up and wrap the legs around
and do things that I necessarily can't
do yeah so I definitely now appreciate
the difference between the two and I
definitely enjoy home sex now more than
I do work sex whereas I when I was a bit
younger I was getting sex I was happy
that was it so I think now just with the
experience of more sexual experiences
I'm able to sort of realize what I
really enjoy and what I can sort of
focus more time on uh for me I think
things have changed like
now I don't really have sex unless it's
like for work like for me of course
there's like this preparation there's
effort to really put into me like having
sex with somebody so I'm like if I'm
gonna have sex I might as well video it
and if I'm if they're not called
videoing and stuff I'm just like well
this is not really worth my time like
I'm already having sex with you like at
least get let me get something else like
oh my God let me get some content out of
this you know I mean so
but it might change in the future I I
did that and lived that and I felt that
it became detrimental because you kind
of like especially with like only fans
and things like that it was like I just
missed the point that I couldn't have
like I just want to have a look on my
own and it was like oh no hang on get
the ring light okay right Lube everyone
ready
whereas actually I just want to like get
out of the shower the parents you know
this is for me not you and it got to
that thing that every time I was having
sex oh well yeah it comes and it kind of
lost the the fun and as I say I think
through time having to that's where I've
learned the difference between work sex
and home sex and it was really important
just to make time for you and your
partner or yourself whatever but have
sex for you as well not just just the
camera you can blur the line between
performance
you burn out that way yeah a little bit
of Separation every you know enjoy the
weekend it doesn't have to be up at the
weekend but you need to take some time
out for me like to be honest I prefer
this sort of stuff like I'm somebody who
enjoy showing off like more than just
the like the clubs and stuff like we
like show myself that's why sometimes I
like to watch my own stuff like on
camera Jimmy so
in some way it makes it more fun for me
that way and then I feel like because
there's the camera watching me I kind of
perform better too it's like my
motivation behind like you know going
from like oh like everyone's watching me
I bet I look hot I better do like how I
want to do it and like yeah that's how I
thought I guess that's the fun part I
think that's great and if that's that's
how you you enjoy it and experiencing
awesome and the day that flips and you
feel pressure that you've got to look
sexy and you've got to be hot and you've
got to be what they want that's when the
dynamic changes only fans has completely
changed the sex industry
I like it what do you think is that true
or not very true um yeah only fans has
completely changed the adult industry
um from my side of it anyway from
production terms it used to be
production companies uh very
professional companies you'd have to
work really hard to get a cast in or to
even get someone to give you a shot
especially as male Talon um if they're
paying all this money out for cruise
locations girls talents testing Etc the
chance of risking it on a new guy is is
very very dubious but now you can
literally go on Twitter create a only
fans page get some collabs in and create
a Show reel with 10 girls then put that
to a producer or something
um you think it's cool as well because
like before I had only fans like I was
going to do porn but then I find out
about the site and I just thought it was
so cool the way like you can make your
own unique site like own and like Niche
own videos the way you want to make them
kind of like amateur content which I
feel like lots of guys prefer to see
like real content more of those instead
like set up cameras like my actual life
like my actual sex life like I'm
recording so it's like the inside almost
to just a normal girl like a normal
student but then she has this only fans
where it's like you can look in and see
a different side so I feel like people
like that kind of personal aspect and
you've got more control yeah exactly
with that I mean you can do you know
obviously within the rules of the side
but basically you can do as much as you
want you set your own limits and set
your own limits you know there's just so
much more that you can do as an
individual yeah some people don't even
do explicit then there's some people
have like threesomes for some orgies
like it's completely on your terms I
love how I'm like fully independent
about that like there's no one that is
in a middleman that's like no one
telling me what to do whatever like um
there's I never feel like pressured to
do oh like people people have a question
stuff but like it's all up to me at the
end of the day like there's no one like
breathing down like I've got no boss
streaming like it's just we're all what
comes to me like through me like it's my
decision so that's what I love about it
I don't feel scared or like or
uncomfortable any situation
what advice would you give someone who's
just starting in the industry my advice
to anyone looking at embarking in the
adult industry is give it consideration
it's not something that you rush into
it's not something that you say I'm
going to do it tomorrow and I need to be
the best I think you need to think about
it wholeheartedly the implications that
become of that not only for yourself but
your family your friends what you might
want to do later on in life it doesn't
necessarily equate to how you feel in
this moment
um and I think just being very aware of
what you're getting into it does have a
lasting impact on your life not
necessarily a negative one but it is
something that you will have to deal
with forever
um and I think just that's something
that we're not necessarily made aware of
I think the glitz and the glamor of
earning x amount the month on only fans
or living the life where you don't have
to stack shelves or whatever the reason
may be sounds very endearing but as I
say once you actually get into all of
our personal experiences we've all had
within working in this field is
something that isn't clearly explained
to you and it's not a reason to avoid it
but it's something you should definitely
be aware of that's involved within it
yeah that's what I tell people I'm like
do your research because it's like real
world only one percent of us make that
large amount of money there is still one
of those people doing sex work who are
struggling and people outside don't see
that they think like oh sex work I'm
going to earn loads of money actually
loads of people doing it struggling I'm
very fortunate all of my friends they
are struggling they do not like you know
sometimes they don't have enough money
for their rent but they're still doing
sex work because they love it so you
have to think about it like rationally
and like research it a lot yeah I feel
like people start out a lot of the time
for like the wrong reasons because they
want Quick Cash they don't actually see
the other side to it like you do have to
love it don't you want to do it and not
just that like obviously the money's
great but it doesn't mean like a lot of
hate like the hate we get is like crazy
you have to be able to just take it I
feel like people don't realize it's not
just all as you take place
won't do it
I think one of the biggest things is and
it is a negative is that you really need
to think about the effect on your life
with regards to jobs
Etc because once you're out there on the
internet you're out there
and you can't take it back think about
what you want to do in five years time
ten years time 20 years time do you want
a family you know all of those things
you need to think about and then make
your decision and make the decision that
you believe is right for you
[Music]
foreign